earth is a wonderful but delicate place
a perfect balance of events occurred for
this planet to support life
but what if earth spun sideways instead
or what would happen if all the ice
melted overnight we explore what would
happen to earth in these extreme
scenarios this is what if early in the
history of our solar system
something mysteriously knocked earth
slightly off its axis
so today we tilt at 23.5 degrees but
what would happen if we tilted even more
what if earth spun sideways on its axis
well it wouldn't take long before utter
chaos ensued one of the most important
consequences of Earth's axial tilt is
the seasons seasons happen because the
tilt points different courts of the
planet toward the Sun at different times
of the year but the tilt also means that
different parts of the globe received
different amounts of sunlight during
each season and that's where a more
extreme tilt starts to cause problems
right now during the summer in the
northern hemisphere places far north
like Luke Diavik Alaska received 24
hours of sunlight for 82 days straight
because earth is tilted far enough on
its axis that as the planet rotates both
diavik never leaves direct sunlight on
the other hand the contiguous US
receives a max of 17 hours a day because
after that it rotates out of daytime
sunlight and in tonight but if we tilted
Earth's axis even more to 90 degrees the
US would get sunlight 24/7
around-the-clock for months on end and
it's not just the US the entire northern
hemisphere would be like this
at first animals would take advantage of
the extra light to find and eat more
food
just like Alaskan birds which feed their
chicks extra nutrition in the summer
resulting in faster growing babies than
their southern counterparts and plant
growth would explode since they get
their energy directly from sunlight
farms in northern Alaska for example
grow cabbages the size of Rottweilers in
the summer but while animals and plants
would thrive humans wouldn't we evolved
to be active during the day and sleep at
night but if we were exposed to unending
sunlight our brains would stop producing
the hormone melatonin which we need to
sleep at night and that could lead to
sleep deprivation depression and
ultimately a more severe chronic version
of these symptoms called seasonal
affective disorder which already affects
9% of Alaskans compared to just 6% of
the entire United States but that's less
of a worry than the floods temperatures
at the North Pole would more than double
to 38 degrees Celsius from 15 point 5
degrees Celsius that's hotter than
temperatures at the equator today as a
result Greenland's ice cap would melt
causing sea levels to rise by 7 metres
and flood nearly every coastal city on
earth say goodbye to New York Copenhagen
and Tokyo to make matters worse the
warmer seas would trigger stronger and
more frequent hurricanes which form when
sea water evaporates at the surface and
the weather wouldn't get better when
winter comes six months later out of
reach of the sun's direct beams for
months at a time the hemisphere would
get colder than any winter on record
swirls of frigid air called a polar
vortex which are normally dissipated by
warm air in the tropics could travel all
the way down to the equator
imagine blizzards in Florida Brazil
Kenya and all those thriving plants they
die from a lack of sunlight agriculture
would collapse as ecosystems crumble and
mass extinctions pile up and there would
be even more floods because meanwhile
the southern hemisphere is getting
toasty and the South Pole is home to 90%
of the world's ice the constant sunlight
would raise its temperature to 38
degrees Celsius from negative 28 degrees
Celsius melting the ice and raising sea
levels by a whopping 61 metres that's
almost as tall as the Leaning Tower of
Pisa
Greenland's flood would look like a
puddle in comparison so all in all while
a few extra hours and the Summer Sun
would be nice
let's leave the extra seasons to Alaska
and be glad the earth is tilted exactly
as it is humans might have built
civilizations but insects owned the
world after all over half of all known
species are insects so if they all
suddenly vanished you notice no more
summers of singing cicadas and
flickering fireflies no bees to
pollinate apple cherry peach or almond
trees no one to make honey a world
without insects means a world with empty
grocery store shelves but that would be
just the beginning of our problems now
it's impossible to say exactly what
would go down but here's a worst-case
scenario of what could happen if all the
insects disappeared there are a few
insects most people would be happy to
see vanish like mosquitoes they kill
hundreds of thousands of people every
year by transmitting malaria West Nile
virus and other diseases but if they
disappear tomorrow we might actually
miss them there are over 3,000 species
and mosquitoes on earth all of which are
food to birds bats frogs another
animals no more mosquitoes means these
creatures and the animals that eat them
could go hungry the same goes for the
dreaded cockroach a protein-packed meal
for birds rodents and even humans in
some parts of the world if we lost all
four thousand four hundred species of
roach entire ecosystems which struggle
to survive believe it or not we'd have
even worse troubles ahead since we'd
face a serious poop problem without one
of the world's greatest recyclers the
dung beetle you see history has taught
us exactly what happens when these
critters can't do their job back in 1788
the British introduced cattle to
Australia and these cows pooped a lot
each one poops enough to fill five
tennis courts every year but while the
dung beetles back in Britain would eat
and break down cow poo the native
Australian beetles wouldn't touch the
stuff because they evolved to munch only
on dry fibrous marsupial dung so the cow
poop piled up by 1960 the cattle had
carpeted 500,000 acres of pasture in
dung that's enough to cover over half of
Rhode Island and while a little bit of
poop is great for fertiliser
this ocean of dung would flood plants
with nitrogen making it impossible for
anything to grow so imagine if all 8,000
species of dung beetle plus other do
dining insects like flies vanished
worldwide the land would be knee-deep in
you know farmland forests and desert
would all collapse and floating
throughout would be loads of corpses see
most animals won't eat dead bodies
that's where flesh-eating beetles aka
domestics and other corpse munching
insects come in over 500 species of
these grisly Undertaker's live worldwide
devouring dead flesh until nothing but
bone remains
without them there would be fewer
custodians around to clean up the mess
sure there would still be hungry
vultures and bacteria around to help but
it wouldn't be enough so that's where we
can end up in an insect list world
starving to death while drowning in a
sea of poop and corpses 43 percent of
Americans say they're too tired to
function so odds are you're pretty
exhausted some warnings you might even
fantasize about staying in bed forever
Hey look your wish came true you've got
food a bedpan and it and the stream of
podcast to binge everything you need to
never move again but it won't be long
until you realize that you've made a
terrible mistake
people spend lazy Sundays or sick days
in bed all the time and are no worse for
wear but if you don't start moving again
after about 24 hours one of the first
things to change is your lungs gravity
isn't pulling them down into their
normal position anymore so the lower
part of your lungs will crumble up you
probably won't feel any different but
watch out because it's harder for mucus
to pass through those collapsed passages
so it can get trapped which can infect
your lungs and ultimately lead to
pneumonia that's why doctors tell people
on bedrest to sit up and COFF from time
to time but you're way too engrossed in
those podcasts to remember to cough
within a week your problems only get
worse
you see normally your muscles and bones
help support your weight under gravity
but now that you're lying down they're
out of a job and as the saying goes if
you don't use them
you lose him for every week in bed you
lose about 1% of your bone density
making your bones more brittle and easy
to fracture
that's why astronauts who often go for
months without gravity exercise for at
least 2 hours a day and load up on
calcium in that same week you also lose
1% of your muscle mass particularly in
your thighs butt and shoulders which
you're no longer using now normally
those muscles would suck sugar from your
blood for energy to function but after
just 10 days of bed rest this process
slows down the result all of that onion
can build up in your bloodstream and
lead to type 2 diabetes by week 2 you
can start developing nasty ulcers called
bed sores these form when the bony parts
of your body like your hips tailbone and
ankles press against the same spot for
too long the constant pressure blocks
blood flow killing your skin cells and
if you're not careful they can even rip
through layers of skin and tissue and
expose your bones and muscles which
sounds like the opposite of relaxing
meanwhile those muscles are wasting away
faster than ever after just 2 weeks
you've lost a whopping 10% of your
muscle mass and that causes a new
problem because the less muscle you have
the less oxygen and therefore blood flow
they need so after a month in bed your
heart pumps 30% less blood per beat and
with less oxygen circulating through
your body you feel more tired even
though you've been resting for a solid
month and if you don't get up soon well
you're going to have a hard time ever
getting up again because six months
maybe a year in most of your muscles
have wasted away your bones are too weak
and fragile to bear your weight and your
heart isn't strong enough to do much
work any time soon
meanwhile your brain isn't a happy
camper either after all you've been
stuck in the same room for months
staring at the same walls the same spot
on the ceiling having the same
experiences day after day not great for
mental health to say the least
a study of pregnant women found that bed
rest increased their risk of anxiety and
depression and some women reported
feeling isolated out of control and
imprisoned so no a year of uninterrupted
bed rest is not the relaxing paradise
we'd all a dream it'd be and this is
exactly why doctors try to get their
patients up and walking as quickly as
possible
in the meantime medical staff turned
people every two hours to keep bed sores
at bay and encourage them to do
exercises in bed to get their heart and
muscles working so just keep in mind
there is nothing wrong with a lazy
Sunday morning as long as you're up and
moving before Monday strikes 99% of all
fresh water ice on earth is sitting on
top of Greenland and Antarctica and each
year a little more of it melts into the
ocean normally it would take hundreds to
thousands of years for it all to melt
the way but what if something happened
that caused a massive global melt
overnight as we slept sea levels would
rise by a whopping 66 meters coastal
cities like New York Shanghai and London
would drown in the apocalyptic mass
flood forcing up to 40 percent of the
world's population out of their homes
while all this chaos ensues above ground
something equally sinister is happening
below all that rising salt water will
infiltrate groundwater reserves farther
inland forcing its way into nearby
freshwater aquifers you know the ones
that supply our drinking water
irrigation systems and power plant
cooling systems all those aquifers would
be destroyed not good on top of that the
ice on Greenland and Antarctica is made
of freshwater so when it melts that's
about 69 percent of the world's
freshwater supply that's going straight
into the oceans this will wreak havoc on
our ocean currents and weather patterns
take the Gulf Stream for example it's a
strong ocean current that brings warm
air to northern Europe and relies on
dense salty water from the Arctic in
order to function but a flood of fresh
water would dilute the current and could
weaken or even stop it
altogether without that warm air
temperatures in northern Europe would
plummet and that could spawn a mini ice
age according to some experts that's not
even the worst of it take a look at what
will happen when that last 1% of
freshwater ice that's not part of
Greenland or Antarctica thaws some of
that 1% is sitting in glaciers farther
inland the Himalayan glaciers
specifically who is one of the largest
threats because of what's trapped inside
toxic chemicals like
dichlorodiphenyltrichloroethane or DDT
scientists discovered that glaciers like
this can store these chemicals for
decades but as they thaw those glaciers
release the chemicals into rivers lakes
and groundwater reserves poisoning each
one as they go the rest of that 1% is
hanging out underground mostly in the
Arctic tundra as something called
permafrost
herma frost is organic matter that's
been frozen in the ground for two-plus
years now one of the most immediate
problems with thawing permafrost would
be mercury poisoning that's right there
are an estimated 15 million gallons of
mercury stored up in the Arctic
permafrost
that's almost equal to the amount of
mercury everywhere else on earth on top
of that the organic matter in permafrost
is a tasty meal for microorganisms after
they digest it all they fart out two of
the most potent greenhouse gases out
there carbon dioxide and methane
scientists estimate this could double
the current levels of greenhouse gases
in the atmosphere and potentially caused
global temperatures to rise by 3.5
degrees Celsius compared to today
that might not sound like much but say
goodbye to that mini European Ice Age
and even rivers and lakes around the
world they'd evaporate from the higher
temperatures and cause mass droughts and
desert like climates and all that extra
water vapor in the atmosphere would fuel
more frequent and stronger storms floods
and hurricanes so all of that newly
established coastline on the eastern US
would be one of the last places you'd
want to live instead there would be mass
migrations to Canada Alaska the Arctic
and even what's left of the Antarctic
and you're right this is probably never
going to happen
after all there's enough ice right now
to cover the entire continent of North
America in a sheet a mile thick so the
next time you hear about record-breaking
heat or ultra powerful hurricanes at
least you know that it could be worse
but scientists estimate that if we don't
take action and global temperatures
increase by just one degree Celsius the
effects of climate change we already see
today will be irreversible so yes it
could be worse and it will be if
not careful earth zooms around the Sun
at 110,000 km/h but what if it just
stopped well for one thing you'd have
only a month to live first off if earth
stops short you'd actually die
immediately because you'd fly off the
planet and hurtle into space just like
you lurch forward in a car when a driver
slams on the brakes but if Earth slows
down more gradually
you'd instead suffer a slower but still
horrific death that's because the planet
is about to get very very hot you see
the sun's tremendous gravity pulls the
earth right toward it meanwhile the
planet is trying to whizz away in this
direction this tug of war keeps us in
orbit but if the earth slows down and
stops the Sun wins and Yanks us toward
our doom in fact a model from the
University of Colorado shows us how long
that terrible trip would take just two
months in the first week you wouldn't
notice much of a change the average
global temperature would climb less than
one degree Celsius and hover around 16
degrees for another week but the closer
we'd get the stronger the sun's pull and
the faster we go this causes the
temperature to rise exponentially by day
21 global temperatures will have jumped
to 35 degrees that's hotter than an
average day in the Sahara and with
desert heat comes desert droughts
sparking wildfires and killing crops UV
radiation from the Sun is so strong we
get severe sunburn after just 15 minutes
outdoors at this point our bodies also
will have hit the
upper limit of their heat tolerance any
hotter and heat stroke can set in
leading to exhaustion delirium or even a
coma and guess what it gets hotter by
day 35 global temperatures will reach 48
degrees
that's as hot as an average summer day
in Death Valley one of the hottest
places on earth most mammals birds and
insects die as the proteins that make up
their cells start to cook yes even
roaches can't withstand this apocalypse
if we want to live we need some indoor
air conditioning stat except the amount
of energy you need to run millions of AC
units at once would wipe out power grids
around the world so with no way to keep
cool humanity dies by day 41 the earth
has passed by Venus we're now the second
planet from the Sun and temperatures
have climbed to 66 degrees but believe
it or not some creatures still cling to
life like thermos aquaticus a bacteria
that lives in Yellowstone's hot geysers
but less than a week later temperatures
are hot enough to boil water and kill
even that bacteria by day 54
temperatures surpass 160 degrees and the
last remnant of life on Earth flickers
out soon after the barren planet crosses
Mercury's orbit for its last week of
existence Earth is the first planet from
the Sun until day 65 the final day by
now the sun's extreme gravity stretches
the planet into an oval shape and magma
begins to leak through the crust at
about noon earth tears apart
liquid rock as temperatures hit 3800
degrees our planet is no more in 1815
Mount Tambora erupted in Indonesia
killing an estimated 92 thousand people
it was the biggest eruption in recorded
history and yet Tambora was about 1/7
the size of the smallest supervolcano
there are about a dozen of these
monsters worldwide and the last one went
off twenty six thousand five hundred
years ago in New Zealand blanketing most
of its island in a layer of thick ash
now it's extremely unlikely that one of
these super volcanoes would go off
anytime soon let alone multiple
eruptions at once but for curiosity's
sake what would happen if all the
world's super volcanoes erupted at once
[Music]
if every supervolcano went off you'd
have a hard time finding a safe place to
flee to because almost every continent
is home to at least one supervolcano for
example there is a Yellowstone in the
u.s. in Goro Goro in Tanzania and Toba
in Indonesia so basically no matter
where you are you're out of luck but at
least you'll have a warning because
weeks or months beforehand the ground
will tremble with earthquakes then
day arrives the earth-shattering sound
would be a dead giveaway that something
wasn't right when Krakatoa which wasn't
even close to the size of a supervolcano
erupted in 1883 it released a roar so
loud the sound traveled nearly four
thousand eight hundred kilometers across
the Indian Ocean shattering windows and
deafening people in its path and since
even the smallest super eruption would
dwarf Krakatoa's eruption there is
really no telling how much damage this
would cause but it would be epically
catastrophic and let's say you were
lucky enough to survive this first wave
of destruction after that it would be
time to find a fallout shelter because
these super eruptions spew billions of
tons of ash volcanic glass and Rock
thousands of meters into the air not
something you want to inhale or be in
the path of since this cloud of ash
doesn't just travel up it also expands
out crashing across the landscape and
jet fighter speeds it would collapse
buildings contaminate water supplies and
bring down any power grids in its path
and the fallout would extend for
hundreds of kilometers so any cities
near by a supervolcano are immediately
toast as are any planes that attempt to
fly people away from the danger and keep
in mind that ash travels when Toba
erupted 74,000 years ago winds blew ash
all the way to India so if all the super
volcanoes go off at once volcanic debris
would spread across the globe when the
eruption ends the disaster will have
only just started because for the next
six months much of that super volcanic
ash would linger in the stratosphere and
block sunlight causing global
temperatures to plunge by as much as 15
degrees Celsius that's close to the
difference between summer and Rio versus
Anchorage Alaska in fact just live
Mount Tambora eruption alone set off the
year without a summer where Frost's and
blizzards plagued much of the northern
hemisphere so multiply that by the
twelve or so super volcanoes all spewing
thick black dust and you've got a
worldwide volcanic winter for the next
few years
tropical forests which can't handle cold
weather would wither and die bringing
down the millions of animal species that
live there and it's about to get even
weaker
you know that saying out of the frying
pan and into the fire well in addition
to ash those volcanoes also belch toxic
gases like sulfur dioxide into the
atmosphere and after a few years just
after the winter finally ends those
gases would start to fall from the sky
as acid rain when the locky volcano
erupted in 1783 in Iceland
it rained down so much sulfuric acid
that it devastated farmland and wiped
out half of all livestock the next year
a full quarter of Iceland's population
died in the resulting famine so imagine
that but everywhere and since locky
wasn't even a super volcano
we're looking in acid rain for the next
decade
say goodbye to civilization because it
probably can't survive a decade-long
global famine now there are a few places
on earth that while still suffering from
cold and acid rain and famine would at
least be free from the actual explosions
themselves like volcanic islands such as
the Galapagos or even Hawaii which
ironically is famous for its volcanoes
but the thing is these volcanoes slowly
release flows of lava rather than
violently exploding so you could at
least enjoy a nice view as civilization
implodes every Christmas Eve certain
traditions say that Santa has just one
night to deliver presents to
millions of children around the globe
now this might seem unreasonable from a
scientific perspective but we wondered
exactly how unreasonable is it overall
it's difficult to determine how many
people around the world celebrate a
Sante centric Christmas on December 25th
but if we consider certain religious and
cultural traditions we get a rough
estimate of about 600 million people now
let's say each household has on average
two and a half kids so Santa only needs
to visit 240 million homes even better
he is more time to get the job done than
you might think
legend has it that he drops by when the
kids are asleep so that gives him eight
hours right well hold up we mustn't
forget about time zones
there are 24 broad time zones worldwide
each one hour apart so factor in the
different Christmas Eve start times
across the planet and kringles got a
luxurious 31 hours to make his
deliveries unfortunately this is where
his luck runs out because just to reach
every house he'll have to fly 1200 times
faster than the world's fastest jet
fighter that's a lot to ask of nine
reindeer which can only gallop up to 80
kilometers per hour on average way too
slow but to be fair that's the best they
can do on the ground since we don't know
exactly how fast a reindeer can fly
let's assume they can manage those
incredible speeds even then the load
they have to lug is much too heavy for
them if every kid receives a single
mid-sized lego set the bag alone would
weigh a whopping 600,000 tons or about
20 Statue of Liberty's meanwhile the
average reindeer can pull up to twice
their weight or about 225 kilograms so
those deer aren't going anywhere and
even if they could
it wouldn't be pretty for starters the
team would create a massive sonic boom
as they hurtle through the air at 3,000
times faster than the speed of sound
deafening any bystanders on the ground
below
Merry Christmas folks but it gets worse
once Rudolph and Co take off they
vaporize before they reached their first
house just like how a rocket heats up
when it reactors the atmosphere at
tremendous speeds the reindeer would
heat to blistering temperatures that
would turn them into venison jerky and
Santa wouldn't fare much better because
he's sitting on what amounts to the
worst rollercoaster ride on earth when a
typical coaster accelerates you get
pushed back against your seat but in
Santa's case to accelerate to those
extreme speeds makes for a much stronger
push a force tens of thousands of times
stronger than gravity would pin him to
the sleigh smashing his bones and
internal organs to jelly but it's not
all doom and gloom let's assume Santa
and Friends miraculously survived this
ordeal he slips his conveniently
boneless body through chimney after
chimney drops off the gifts and now gets
to munch on his well-deserved treats a
lot of treats if every household offers
him three sugar cookies and one 8-ounce
glass of whole milk that's 720 million
cookies and enough milk to fill 23
Olympic swimming pools total now that
adds up to three hundred ninety six
billion calories plenty to see him
through his hibernation until Christmas
comes round again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you